hey I'm Kira hey I'm Stephanie I'm Brent
my name is Jason what are we doing today
I have no idea
well today we are doing something that
you in the comments have been asking for
for a while and the show today
we are going to be drawing each other
[Music]
all right Kevin all right Jackie
guys are you cute or should I draw you
oh you draw me however you want to draw
me okay
how should I draw you draw me in your
style my style is just mean
okay draw me in your style but improve
upon it so that it so it doesn't look
like me your that's a tall order Jackie
but I will try my best
just like what does Jason look like
things just gonna draw you looking down
because that's how I remember you
working on this you got a big smile
actually you've got more features than I
do I feel like are you done like
caricatures for portraits before I've
always had a hard time with it cuz
people are like make me look real like
don't be afraid to make me look ugly
nice dog what do you justice hmm this is
not this is hard this is hard
yeah sure I feel like I should go with
the cute route I don't think I should
try to draw you realistically yeah wait
smile Daisy yeah now I think it's really
hard to draw people that you know
because you don't want to offend them
because you're like even if you're like
no this actually looks good or accurate
you're worried if they might be like is
that really what you think I look good
yeah I'm struggling was this a bad idea
it was a bad idea I think boy
but we've already committed we're doing
it we can't stop we're doing it
you have chess here I do not think I
need to see I think you need to take out
your shirt needs to take off my shirt
there's no other way I'm gonna no this
will feed into the other comments that I
think we're in a relationship what
people think I've seen of you know I
ship it and I showed I showed my wife
I'm like look at this is she's like tell
the comment section you were married
for a married man heaven Jackie not a
lot of hair that was mean why would you
say that you do I'm seeing you in a
pride no look I know I know I have a
huge forehead so I'm with it have fun
with it I have a friend that recently
got married and I've been trying to draw
like a portrait of him and his wife and
I've got every like I've got the bodies
figured out I've got everything figured
out except for the faces like I just not
unable to to get the faces down at all
you know I always just end up making
people just cartoons it was like you're
just this is your new face this is
actually kind of my nightmare becoming
hey I am not good at likenesses hmm
here's how bad at caricatures I am okay
I actually have a site bad caricatures
com where people can go and pay me five
dollars to draw a terrible caricature of
them I will send them the terrible
character chair and a written apology
you know what Kevin there's nothing
wrong with it you know what you're good
at I know what I'm not good at
yeah we're just caricatures did you have
that middle school sketch book that's
just full of like beautifully rendered
eyes I did a lot of hands when I was a
kid I did a lot of um epic poses with
people with fists yeah yeah yeah that's
a fun way to learn figure drawing is to
do comic characters yeah so I drew like
this funny because my friends would be
like Jason can draw anything with
muscles yeah boys and their muscle
drawing yeah so everyone would be ripped
the big tip that kind of changed the way
that I drew as a as a kid was draw I see
you don't rely on on symbols and kind of
your assumption of what something looks
like like actually take time to look at
your subject at the face at the features
process them as if you've never seen it
before then dry you folding a pen oh
because they will signal that you are an
artist and this is a portrait of an
artist the whole thing I've always heard
is like learn the fundamentals before
you break them yeah because I feel like
yeah a lot of people are like oh
well you're just drawing super cartoony
so you can probably just you know you
need to learn how to draw realistically
it's like no you should because like
even within the most simple cartoons
there's an intelligent decision making
and like correct Anatomy and proportions
yeah you know even if it looks really
obscure it's still like you can tell it
the person who drew it and knows how to
draw hmm we just we just look up at each
other we're just looking at each other
like what are you just like what do you
look like you design a celebrity to me
celebrity would I be I always struggle
with this what's the guy from 500e this
summer and the Joseph Joseph
gordon-levitt's I know he's got kind of
a very specific face I feel like what
would you assign what celebrity would
you assign me a dress Alva it's just so
weird oh your head a little more focus
yeah I do have a bulbous head you've got
a lot of things I do have a lot of
things sorry this is just doesn't look
like you this doesn't look like you
either what we do we continue we keep
going you know this is probably gonna
lead to a lot of messages in my inbox
being like hey can you join me for free
you do a lot of caricature so I've been
like practicing by drawing friends on my
insta here and there yeah and it's it's
been like really good for capturing like
the essence of somebody somebody yeah
and it's best been like really awesome
to work on I'm drawing you like a Bratz
doll this is not good okay I'm gonna
keep this drawing on the side so you can
see what I started with but I'm going to
go back I'm gonna go cute I'm gonna try
again and I think I'm gonna go full TV
full TV you know which again is not my
style but I think I may be able to do
something more kind of made you sort of
look like Belle from Beauty and the
Beast
I do like that you have weird eyebrows
thanks Jackie not weird like physically
just weird to draw they're an
interesting shape if you will you know
what they call your eyes Kevin what
deeps really I've been told they bug out
Gabe's not today I want to my own horn I
think I I think I might have nailed you
oh my got it iffy if your 95% smile I
think you're pretty much there drawing
Jason I think I know you as like male
model Brent's whoa it's so just normal
Brent nobody's yeah yeah yeah how you
doing Jackie I mean I'm done I know you
are but I'm trying to make this other
one I mean of you even scarier how do
you think you did cute like yeah you're
like like a Disney character cute how
about with me I really enjoyed doing
this I haven't done like a portrait like
in this style in a while and it's it's
really nice it's kind of like um like
anime that's like trying to be realistic
and it's like whisper of the heart kind
of style you seem stressed
Kevin you seem stressed this was a lot
harder than I thought it was gonna be
yeah you came in thinking it was gonna
be easy peasy lemon squeezy
yeah when it was actually hard tea party
right heaven far right well can I be
real for a second it's because I respect
you artists and I don't want to
disappoint you
I'm gonna cry stop it I mean from
disappointment you got me
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
you really got it Wow this is me I love
this oh thanks man I love this too
stop it Kevin you're just being you're
anime is getting great amazed oh it's so
cool that's such a cool style thank you
I love your style too it's like super
expressive this looks like TV father
Jason TV pathogen yeah if I had a TV
show and I was like the dad everyone
loves yeah these are great
I'm flattered by both of them I will say
the one on the left though is
frightening as hell it's scary right
it's very scary sorry this is a really
smart exercise I feel like especially
like you know if you can't really do
life drawing classes or anything you can
just like grab your friend and be like
sit down I'm gonna draw ya really have a
fun drawing session like this like I
love like when you can just invite
people over and just everybody can just
do art together and I think that looks
like me I think this looks like me oh
you did a good job Kevin thank you I
love it and you know what hmm get rid of
your website cuz you have drawn a good
caricature
[Music]
thanks friend yeah I'll give you a hug
oh thank you yeah thank you van thank
you I Love You Man
[Music]